Tibbs called you the best rebounding
guard in the league are you for sure
Russ is up there obviously Luke is up
there I think I am just in terms of
Lucas what six eight Russ is what six
five and athletic I'm like six four six
five I'm not that athletic yeah you like
I'm getting it done yeah I'm I'm here
for a good time you know what I mean so
I think I am just in terms of going
pursuing rebounds in my zone out my zone
I think that's one of those things in my
game I want to be the guy to go gets
offensive Rebound in a one-possession
game get us open shot get us extra
possession do those kind of things
that's what I want that's what I live
for that's how I play that's just kind
of like the mentality that I have
especially in the fourth quarter